in vitro fertilization is a process
where a woman's eggs are fertilized
outside her body then placed back inside
her body to help her get pregnant
a woman's reproductive system includes
the vagina
cervix
uterus
fallopian tubes
and ovaries
during the monthly menstrual cycle one
of the ovaries releases an egg
a process called ovulation
after ovulation the egg enters the
fallopian tube
a woman is most likely to become
pregnant if she has sex in the days just
before during or right after ovulation
during this time a sperm cell from a
man's reproductive fluid called semen is
able to fertilize the egg just inside
the fallopian tube
as it travels along the fallopian tube
the fertilized egg now called an embryo
loses the outer cells that nourished it
in the ovary
the embryo passes from the fallopian
tube into the uterus
in the uterus the embryo sheds its
protective outer layer called the zona
pellucida in a process called zona
hatching
zona hatching is necessary for the
embryo to implant in the tissue lining
the uterus during implantation a
connection between the woman and the
embryo begins to grow
this organ called the placenta allows
oxygen and nutrients to pass from her to
the embryo
in vitro fertilization may be performed
if a woman has been having trouble
getting pregnant a condition known as
infertility or it may be done if a woman
wants to have a child without a male
partner
before in vitro fertilisation a woman
will receive fertility medication that
causes more than one egg to grow and
mature in the ovaries
a man will provide a semen sample so
that the healthiest sperm can be
collected for fertilization if the male
partner is completely infertile also
known as sterile or the woman doesn't
have a male partner a donor may be
arranged to provide sperm for this
process
in vitro fertilization consists of three
main procedures follicle aspiration
fertilization
and embryo transfer
during the first procedure called
follicle aspiration eggs will be
harvested from the ovaries
at the beginning of this procedure an
ultrasound probe will be inserted into
the woman's vagina so that her doctor
can view her ovaries
inside the ovaries the doctor will look
for follicles each follicle is a
fluid-filled sac that contains an egg
then the doctor will insert a long thin
needle into and through the wall of her
vagina and guide it to the ovary a
suction device connected to the needle
will collect several eggs from inside
their follicles
during the second part of in-vitro
fertilisation called fertilization the
collected eggs will be taken immediately
to a laboratory where they will be
fertilized
fertilization may be performed by
insemination where several sperm are
mixed with the healthiest eggs
or the eggs may be fertilized with sperm
injected directly into them during a
process called intracytoplasmic sperm
injection
the fertilized eggs also called embryos
will be monitored for three to five days
as they begin to grow
at this time the lab may create a hole
in the zona pellucida surrounding some
of the embryos this process called
assisted hatching will help these
embryos implant in the uterus some of
the embryos will be used right away for
embryo transfer
and the rest will be frozen and stored
for future use if necessary
vitro fertilisation is called embryo
transfer which is done three to five
days after fertilization during embryo
transfer a tool called a speculum will
be inserted into the woman's vagina
so that the doctor can see her cervix a
syringe will be loaded with fluid
containing one or more of the hatched
embryos then the syringe will be
attached to a long thin tube called a
catheter
the doctor will insert the catheter into
the vagina through the cervix and into
the uterus
once inside the uterus the doctor will
inject the embryos
then the catheter and speculum will be
removed
the woman may continue to lie on her
back for about 15 minutes